you mentioned burnout what do the the
sort of signs and symptoms of burnout
look like with the people that you you
coach through careertech i think there's
different stages so i think we'll start
off in that place of you know we all
want to do well if you're driven you
will want to kind of like excel but then
it it moves into that state where
it's the progression or the the movement
or the doing is then outweighing
just looking after your general self
and you
other people are starting to notice that
in you but you're not ready to accept it
or acknowledge it yet there's that cycle
of just general irritability with other
people maybe you are
frustrated with lack of pace the way
that people are doing things you're
starting to nitpick and depending on how
you exhibit stress some people go into
that kind of fight mode where they're a
little bit more micromanaging over
analytical and then other people will
generally slow down so they might
actually completely become
desensitized lean back very immobile or
move into people-pleasing
and so i think when we get into that
point as well we then can suffer from
quite a lot of stomach issues
gastrointestinal kind of problems that's
when it's often been the stress has been
underlying in the body for quite a while
and then lots more
psychological concerns around loneliness
or just you know that fear of
not being good enough and then what does
that lead to in terms of who am i and
what's my place and
do people will people miss me like it
can spiral so i think we can go through
lots of different stages it's just
noticing how do i catch myself when i've
been pushing too hard or doing too much
and actually not listening to those that
can notice these signs before i have
perhaps yeah and so if we find ourselves
like catching those kind of early
warning signs what are the things that
we can do to kind of reverse things or
remedy things so i think it's definitely
noticing like how are you triggered
around stress like what is causing you
to
feel out of sorts or to be irritable you
know some people also have more physical
symptoms so you might be noticing
actually if i've constantly got colds
and i'm run down or my joints are aching
or you know like
how do we take a moment and pause and
think actually what might have been
going on in the way that i'm eating
or the way that i could slow what can i
slow down what can i start to delegate
let go of some people it might be
through memory loss so what am i filling
my brain with so a lot of people suffer
from cognitive symptoms that are a bit
more about you know forgetfulness or
feeling massively overwhelmed all the
time and you know what could you do to
create some more white space in your
calendar
so moving i think sometimes we try to
move from like deep attention tasks you
know the stuff that could we can get
through in 90 minutes and like blitz on
that and then we have more of the kind
of open attention stuff which is emails
and stuff like that but where's the
white space in between that the time to
just do nothing maybe just to go into
nature just to
pause for a second to eat to just be i
don't think there's enough of that in
the calendar for many people
i think there's also something about the
arts you know just spent a year doing
a therapeutic arts and educational
program and it's looking at how through
the art making process our brain changes
and kind of helps us to problem solve
differently to disassociate from stress
and that could also just be through
fitness it could be through going to see
something
creative but that has the power to help
us to relax and to loosen tension and
stress hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day